[Music]
a bone found at lake mead one year ago
but this is the first time the public is
hearing about it as the eight news now
i-team exposes what happened it seems a
mistake may have been made after the
discovery while one government agency
refuses to answer questions another says
it has no documentation well the
i-team's vanessa murphy has been working
on on this all week long to find you
answers she has more now from mohave
county arizona
this is where one family says they found
a bone here at lake mead we're at south
cove this is where the colorado river
begins to form the lake now what's
unclear is what the national park
service did with the bone we were
standing out there bruce barker says he
was here with his family in july of 2021
when his granddaughter kimmy who we
talked with via zoom made a discovery i
would reach down picked it up and i was
like look at that then i went off to my
grandpa and i go grandpa look what i
found appeared to be a human femur he
says they later called the national park
service when you contacted them what
were your hopes
well my hope was that it would actually
be a human femur and they could do some
dna and do a
give somebody closure on what might have
happened to maybe their loved ones but
the 8 news now i-team has learned that
never happened after reaching out to the
national park service multiple times by
phone email and even showing up at the
boulder city office we received this
email stating medical officials
determined the bone was not human so we
reached out to the mohave county medical
examiner's office and a manager said the
office sent a photo to a forensic
anthropologist who said it was an animal
bone and then the bone was destroyed
that would be a tragedy if that is what
happened the i-team showed these photos
to two board-certified forensic
anthropologists so that's the thigh bone
the upper bone of the leg
are you one hundred percent sure
yeah
yeah that's a femur so it's all very
distinctively a human bone when we asked
the medical examiner's office for
documentation the manager said there is
none she also refused to provide the
name of the forensic anthropologist who
she said reviewed a photo and the head
of the office said there's no
correlating case in their files if i get
a case in and it's not human it still
goes in my logbook i still retain the
emails or i retain the text messages
however i got that
so
that's a problem the national park
service stated it entered the bone into
evidence but what remains unclear is
whether the agency then handed it to the
medical examiner's office or sent a
photo the agency repeatedly ignored our
questions would any trained forensic
anthropologist think that's an animal
bone
i shouldn't think so bruce barker points
out when his granddaughter found that
bone one year ago the lake was 27 feet
higher vanessa murphy live local now